more the cast forms a sense of
camaraderie while shooting the movie
Damon added that Killian Murphy who
plays Jay Robert Oppenheimer himself
wouldn't join them blunt mentions on
Murphy would eat just one almond for
most nights he was losing so much weight
for the part that he just didn't eat
dinner the end result is that Murphy's
Oppenheimer looks quite emaciated
throughout much of the film of course
Murphy isn't the first actor to go to
extreme methods in order to lose weight
for a rower Christian Bale attempted
something similar in The Machinist while
Jake Gyllenhaal did the same for
Nightcrawler kylian Murphy followed in
that trajectory so that he could look
more like the real J rubber Oppenheimer
he discussed his intentions with his
physicality in May when speaking with
the New York Times mentioning I love
acting with my body and Oppenheimer had
a very distinct physicality and
silhouette which I wanted to get right
meanwhile others debated whether such
extreme commitment is needed in this day
and age one to the user wrote in a
computer-generated Cinema landscape
there's no reason to eat one almond a
day for a roll